Today, we'd like to
discuss tension in a rope.
Under what conditions
is the tension uniform?
Recall that if we had a rope
and say we were pulling-- here's
our one end.
We'll call that we're pulling
at this end with the force a.
And we pull on this
end b with a force b.
Then what we meant by tension
at any point in the rope
was that we took an
imaginary slice of the rope p
and we looked at the two sides.
And here-- if we call this
the left side and this is
the right side-- then
on the left side,
we have that the
right side of the rope
is pulling the left side of
the rope by some force f.
And this is the left side.
And the right side is being
pulled by the left side.
So that's the right side
being pulled by the left.
And what we define the
tension at the point p
was to be the magnitude of
this action-reaction pair.
And that's how we define tension
at a point inside a rope.
Now we'd like to address the
question, under what conditions
can we say that the
tension is uniform?
Which means that at all points
p, the tension is the same.
In order to analyze this, we'll
apply Newton's second law.
So let's begin with the
same situation as before.
Let's consider a rope where
we're pulling this side
with a force at the end.
By the way, we can call the
tension at that end T of a.
And on this side,
we can refer to this
as the tension on side b.
Now suppose that our mass
of the rope is non-zero.
And we now want to apply
Newton's second law.
But let's also
apply the condition
that the acceleration
of the rope is non-zero.
So you're holding the
rope under some tension
by pulling both sides.
But the rope is
not accelerating.
And so what does that mean
when we apply Newton's
second law to the rope?
Well, let's just
arbitrarily call that
our positive direction.
We see by vector decomposition
that we have Tb minus Ta
equals mass of the rope.
But because the acceleration
of the rope is zero,
this side is zero.
And we can use
Newton's second law
to conclude that the
tension in the rope
is uniform when the rope
is not accelerating.
And this is what we'll
call our case one.
A zero tension in
the rope is uniform.
Now let's suppose case
two, that a is not zero.
And so now we have the rope.
This is point b.
Here's point a.
We'll choose a
uniform direction a.
And now we can see
when we apply F equals
Ma, that Tb minus Ta
equals mass of the rope
times the acceleration
of the rope.
So you're pulling such
that Tb is greater
than Ta by precisely
the quantity Mr times a.
So the tension at the
ends are not the same.
And therefore, the tension
in the rope is not uniform.
Now there's a special case
here that we want to consider.
So even though a
is nonzero, let's
assume that the mass of
the rope is very small.
And this is often--
people call this
assume the rope is massless.
Well, that's a little strange.
We can say that the very,
very light string is often
the same type of modeling.
And under those circumstances
with that assumption,
you see that there is
no contribution here.
And with that assumption,
that the tension
is approximately uniform.
Ropes are not massless.
There's a small difference.
But under those circumstances
when we say a very light rope
that-- even if it is
accelerating-- implies
that T is uniform in the rope.
And we can say the rope
is under uniform tension.
And we will often
refer to this case
when we analyze
problems where we're
pulling objects, for instance,
in a typical pulley problem.